hey you guys uh i don't know where the
hell tom is
he's around here somewhere so i decided
i was just gonna go ahead and start
without him because he's taking too long
to get in here
so uh hi it's wednesday and we're gonna
do uh
side tracks today i was going to do a
movie review but started without me
well yeah it was time you're not in here
you're not in here so that's what that's
on you
you told me we had seven minutes yeah
that was seven minutes ago no it was
about three minutes
no it wasn't i was watching on the clock
i know what damn time it is
it's look 301 now he's trying to argue
with me about what time it is well
here's the thing
here's the thing here's the thing that's
awesome she couldn't wait
extra minute for me to show up well i
was like oh [ __ ] that dude
i didn't know how long you were going to
be i didn't know what i know
i didn't know what the hell you're doing
because you never look at the clock and
you never look at the clock
and it's like you're always like out
farting around it's like you'll it's
like you'll be sitting around i'll be
like yeah it's
you know it's three years make sure that
air conditioner was draining i told you
this is what it's like being a man up in
this house that's like i'm making sure
he's [ __ ] i'm making sure this [ __ ]
why didn't you check that like an hour
ago though
well i did yeah i had to go back and
make sure it's still draining i don't
know why i had to put a custom hole in
the bottom of that window unit it kept
[ __ ] backing out flooding my job
not not the main no not the main one no
no no that's your
man cave i got [ __ ] to do up in this
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
all right okay let me start [ __ ]
getting in
see yeah get in here so you're turning
this [ __ ] into a reality tv show
see what you're doing i see exactly what
you're doing i'm not
it's just i didn't know how long you
were going to be and i was like well i
don't want to just sit here [ __ ]
around
and waiting for you i didn't know how
long you were going to be coming back in
just girl excuses
okay okay whatever all right i'm not
allowed to like have an opinion or just
wait a second just wait a second
i didn't know how long you could always
go find me so what are you doing we got
to start the show
that's another thing you could have done
yeah but you knew i told you
seven minutes ago and then you tried to
argue that it was only three minutes
even though it was actually seven
minutes okay
i don't know what it is that you already
are doing
yeah see no tom has no sense of time
exactly
these [ __ ] girls ganging up on me and
[ __ ] you've said that yourself
you've said that yourselves all right
whatever i have to remind you every
single day like what time
[ __ ] is because you don't ever you don't
ever look at that look at pokey's hand
coming up underneath the table is she
coming
what's she doing
why can't she open it i don't know
usually she can just push it open
she didn't think about what's the matter
pokey okay oh my goodness these kitties
she's been spoiled all [ __ ] day i
know she's always spoiled
that's what's really funny i came in um
i got a video of it i'll put it on the
on the main show on saturday but uh i
came in my office this morning after i
went out for my walk and it was still
early so it was still kind of dark and i
was like putting my [ __ ]
headphones up or whatever over there and
all of a sudden i hear
and i turned around and beijing was
sitting in my new office chair
like just like a little queen and i was
like oh look at you and i started t
i started videotaping her and talking to
her and of course pookie couldn't have
that so she came in the office she's
getting ready to tear her into those
[ __ ] clothes
packages look at her oh she's doing it
folks
she can play with the paper yeah as long
as she doesn't like tear the shirt
she'll try to tear it open
amazon's gonna show up any minute start
bringing the damn doorbell while we're
doing the show too
i think i mean it's supposed to there's
i'm supposed to have a package today
i think it might be i had to buy pookie
a little
like uh like a little cube thing because
she likes to jump
up and down on the bathroom counter like
to get in the bathroom sink and
everything
and i just feel like i don't know i just
feel like when she jumps off the counter
like onto the floor
it all it seems like it hurts she's like
yeah you know what i mean
maybe not but it's like i don't want her
joints getting all [ __ ] up when she
gets older so i don't know
well you know there used to be a chair
there and it's not there anymore so it's
like she doesn't have anything to jump
on
all right so what's going on for today
what do we got to talk about not much
actually because like i said we
you know normally i was gonna actually
do a matinee today but then
last night like i got all my work done
and then i got in the room and
i was like do you feel like watching a
new movie and he was like not really and
i was like yeah i don't either
i was like maybe we'll just do a side
tracks tomorrow and then i got
distracted by
netflix because they just put up a new
season of
sugar rush so i had to start watching
that yeah not my thing
do you guys ever have you guys seen that
it's like for some reason
i'm not super into like reality shows or
competition shows or anything
but any one stop it pokey no
any ones that are about um
like like cake boss or those kind of
anything that's like about cake
decorating or making desserts or
anything like that like that um
[ __ ] what's that australian dude's
bald dude's name
zumbo or whatever his name is he has one
too it's called just desserts which is
also really good
but um i i don't know why i'm just like
really really into those they don't make
me hungry or anything like that i just
like like the creativity i guess
they have another one that i think is
called nailed it
and that's like people that don't really
know how to bake and they're just like
[ __ ] stuff
up and i don't i i don't like that one i
don't really like reality shows or
competition shows like world's worst
cooks or anything like that but it's
like i don't really like reality shows
just
that are just showing people [ __ ] up
and you can laugh at them i'm not
really into that i think i like um
the dessert ones because i like seeing
like what people they give them a theme
and then i like seeing what people come
up with and then how well they execute
it
like i like them to be good at it i
don't like to
see like a pathetic looking one they
also had another show on netflix that i
kind of tried to get into because it
sounded really cool
they had one what the [ __ ] it called i
think it's called blown away or
something like that but it's about glass
blowers and i was like oh that's random
and uh so i started watching it because
you know i like dale chihuly and
all that kind of glass blown art kind of
stuff so i started watching it and it's
like it was kind of cool but they didn't
really give them enough time to do
anything super spectacular plus most of
the comp competitors were kind of
douches and i couldn't really put up
with it
so i didn't finish it but i'm definitely
gonna finish sugar rush i think i've
watched
all of the they had a christmas one they
had a [ __ ] i watch all that [ __ ]
that's like the only reality show type
of [ __ ] that i watch other than like
gordon ramsay i'll watch anything ken
saying that he liked the unseen hands it
was awesome
oh thank you um there's no lag uh tom
the
guy tom's car a lot there's no lag
because you got a new laptop
yeah and we're on a land now we're on a
land cable yeah we have an ethernet
cable ethernet uh and plus i'm using obs
to stream like instead of streaming
directly from youtube
yeah uh we've got all kind of upgrades
look i got a new office chair yeah you
guys saw that
yeah she's still um trying to figure out
how to perfect this [ __ ] streaming
thing because there's a lot of controls
there
a lot of ways to you know program it to
announce and a lot of ways to mess up
i didn't realize that when we did the um
i can't remember what it was a couple
days ago when we did that matinee
and i put up that picture of moon pie
yeah like that lady
um i didn't realize that if you just
went to a picture
like on the scenes on obs that it would
like knock out the
audio yeah so it just went silent while
that picture was on it wasn't like a
huge deal
because i think what you have to do is
you have to there's a way around it you
have to copy
this scene that you're looking at right
now like us live and then
and then make a new scene and then slap
a picture over it and
for each picture you have to make a new
scene so i was like that seems
it's gotta be another way well that's
how you do it though
that's how you do it maybe there's a way
to show a picture on a half a screen or
a part screen no you can do that but you
have to do it the same way
because otherwise it's just going to
think that you're going to a different
thing
okay you can do a slide show like if you
have a whole bunch of pictures that you
want to show like in succession
you can do that but if you're going to
like space them out i think you have to
like repeat the scene every time i don't
know like i said i learned this [ __ ]
program in like
two hours so yeah we'll figure it out
i'll figure it out one of these
um i think what's going on today um
has been basically a comic book
[ __ ] holocaust uh [ __ ] tnt
who owns uh dc comics
has just [ __ ] annihilated their um
their comic book staff for making shitty
comic books so they're all getting
[ __ ] fired
uh marvel is gonna be next and i was
watching this other thing about what's
going on inside the disney empire
disney's [ __ ] up all kinds of
machiavellian stuff and reorganizing
people's heads [ __ ] people getting
decapitated and fired and [ __ ]
replaced and
it's gonna be a huge change this is a uh
he's a hollywood
screenwriter and a guy that was in the
guild and did all kinds of [ __ ] i forgot
what his name was
um camera i think his name is camera
he's this indian guy or pakistani guy
he's been writing for a long time i
think 20 years and he was just
he doesn't give a [ __ ] he just he just
says what's going on in hollywood and
entertainment
this is going to be a big [ __ ] shift
in um entertainment soon once this
[ __ ] pandemic thing's over and he's
[ __ ] tells real
interesting about what's going on the
movies we've been seeing the pat
this past year were all conceived of
two and three years ago and uh they know
that those movies suck and that they
didn't make much money you know they
were even talking about birds of prey
they said by the time birds of prey came
out
they already knew it was to bomb which
it did
and it's just evidence he said
um in 2021 it's going to be [ __ ]
brand new [ __ ] and um
there's not going to be any kind of
[ __ ] like woke politics in it
because it's going to be for totally
totally about making money
and getting asses into seats says it's
going to look a lot like
70s and 80s writing that's what he said
he says he says it's going to be a time
for [ __ ] good
writers and good stories you know um
so we'll see because basically it's
basically they're getting rid of all the
[ __ ] corporate [ __ ]
they're all getting fired and they're in
it and
he was saying that probably what you'll
see survive
in 2021 is something that looked like
uh like an independent film of today
which that's actually good news
well yeah yeah like i said maybe we'll
see stuff like the 70s where
it'll just kind of go in all directions
like people will just be kind of
yeah you know they can do whatever they
want yeah they evidently the people that
were like producing and all the [ __ ]
investors and [ __ ] they lost all their
money
so so they're just like desperate
they're like
uh you know what's gonna make money you
know and that's that's
the power is shifting around another
thing that they did was is that they got
rid of that law that said a studio could
not own a theater
um which he was explaining that
you know they were trying to stop the
emergence of [ __ ] monopolies
back in the old days before cable and so
the a uh the studio couldn't own a
theater
uh or a theater chain because they would
start doing monopolistic tactics and
stuff so um
but that was for another time you know i
mean when you look at it netflix owns
its own theater
your house so you know what i mean so
every so in order for the
because you know think about it your
house would be kind of like a theater
they're doing their own distribution
yeah what i'm saying so in order to give
the student
in order to give the studios a chance of
survival
they got rid of that law which blocked
them from owning theater chains
so now the studios have a [ __ ]
advantage
they have an incentive now to [ __ ]
buy theater chain or maybe they might
buy
parts of [ __ ] amc you know what i
mean and convert them into their own
theaters but chains of theaters like emc
will probably vanish
that'll probably be carved up amongst
studios
yeah but that's what he that's what he
thinks
but we'll just have to see you know and
[ __ ] entertainment's changing
drastically
next year we'll look nothing like this
year yeah
yeah what episode of hoarders is moonpie
in it is uh
season six episode four i think
her name is shanna there was like the
new hoarders that they just put up on
netflix they i kind of like it better
because they just concentrate on one
person for the whole show
but it seems like all the older ones
that are on 2b
um it's on 2b for free if you want to
watch it by the way um
it's like they'll have like two hoarders
and then it'll go back and forth between
them
you know what i mean so i don't know but
um oh another thing i wanted to say i
made like
this announcement i think like on
facebook and instagram and all that
other kind of [ __ ]
but we're doing some new stuff for
uh fall upcoming i've already mentioned
that i'm gonna start doing horror book
reviews
i'm gonna put one up every week it'll
probably be on mondays and the first one
is gonna go up monday august 31st just
in time for
september coming up patrons will get to
see it a day early like you do with most
of our other videos
also um i wanted to get like
a little more interaction like with the
the patrons
so what i'm gonna start doing again
starting in um
at the end of august beginning of
september is every week i'm gonna post
polls um and i'm gonna give you like
five choices
as to like what older movie you want us
to do for the retrospective and also
like five choices what you want the
topic to be for the upcoming
main episode making it more interactive
yeah
and like you know it'll let me gauge
like the interest
in the stuff because like as it's as it
is now i'm basically just like pulling
out so
like if shutter adds something or if i
find something on 2b or if somebody
sends us a dvd or something or a blu-ray
then we usually just do that or we push
it forward but sometimes i'm kind of
like left lost i don't really know
which one i feel like doing and so it'll
kind of help me out so what i did with
the first one i have the first
post it'll go up like at the end of
august and um
i just picked like five movies that i
thought would be cool to review and that
are available
like on 2b or shutter or whatever and uh
so
you guys can go in there if you're a
patron you can go in there and vote
and uh the one that gets the most votes
we'll do it and if nobody votes then
i'll just pick one
we're talking about moon pie that one
guy's got a lot of face
wait for a lady what you're missing
when we showed that photograph and we
lost the audio i was talking about her
during that time but that never made it
on the show
yeah i didn't realize it until after
until i watched the play what i was
saying
during during the time that she was
showing you the photograph
i was saying that if you look at her all
right
she looks like a three-dimensional
representation of a south park character
she looks like [ __ ] a cartman or
something like that
her head is a [ __ ] total sphere it's
totally spherical
from every [ __ ] angle yeah it's just
like a
like a [ __ ] moon pie yeah like a 3d
moon pie like a moon by spinning
like if you were to spin a moon pie on
its edge like a [ __ ] coin
that's what her head looks like [ __ ]
big bitch-ass teeth and [ __ ] she's
[ __ ]
i i normally don't pick on people all
the time you know for how they look but
yeah you do
yeah because people are responsible for
how they look
most of the time unless they awesome
unless they got some kind of illness
but you know i'm responsible for how i
look
[ __ ] i put my time in the gym
you sit around [ __ ] just eating candy
and [ __ ] [ __ ] in bottles you're
gonna end up [ __ ] looking like
something like that they think they
killed me
and [ __ ] one yeah one gallon [ __ ]
bottles
and leaving that [ __ ] in her house and
all over her yard as a one-woman plague
a plague and pestilence of the [ __ ]
neighborhood
two things the bottles no sympathy the
bottles that she was using uh was she
like pooping in a bucket and then
pouring into the drink yeah it was
sloshing all around on her [ __ ] hands
didn't you see that
yeah all right because i was sitting
there going like now
the bottles that she was using were like
those apple juice bottles like the ones
we get like from sam's and i was like
yeah those are like they're big like
that but then the mouth of them is
really small
and i'm like is she like yeah does she
she's in that house and she didn't wash
her hands
yeah after that [ __ ] that [ __ ] is
[ __ ] crazy yeah so that was the first
thing because
all i could think of at first i was like
oh i guess she's pouring the poop into
the bottles instead of just like trying
to squat over this tiny hole
like in the bottle and pooping directly
in the bottle the second thing
and i think i mentioned this before was
that i could not
it blew my mind ken said head's a death
star
her head is a [ __ ] death card [ __ ]
right man
it blew my mind that she
didn't realize that her whole entire
house and yard smelled like [ __ ]
you know what i mean like that she
seemed kind of surprised
when they told her that she's like yeah
they've told me there's like a musty
smell she kept saying musty yeah she
thought there was mold
yeah and everybody's like no your house
and your yard are full of poop and so
everything just smells like poop
really i can't smell it yeah and she was
just like seemed flabbergasted by that
information smelling there's just
[ __ ] [ __ ] bottles laying around
everywhere
and i'm like really no really you can't
smell it that place is a [ __ ]
biohazard it must have like burned out
her like
me just hear your nose nodes
yeah i guess there's just so much of it
her nose just gave up and went nope
i couldn't live next to somebody like
that if somebody lived there next to me
i'd [ __ ] toss them i'll talk cocktail
well that's what i mean i'm surprised
your neighbors didn't just burn the
place down gotta burn that [ __ ] down
i mean all that poop maybe there's like
that'd be good kindling well that would
call it the authorities that would have
called the authorities in you know what
i mean if i can demolish the place as a
biohazard
but that [ __ ] that place is [ __ ]
disgusting you got an open sewer
in the [ __ ] house next to you yeah
pretty much you know this is a
civilization there's got to be certain
standards
the other man [ __ ] even neanderthal
didn't would not live like that
that's what i was saying i was just like
i was like animals don't live like that
animals don't animals don't live like
that there was a cat in that house suzy
out the door hadn't [ __ ] vanished
never saw that cat again yeah she was
only in one shot i was just like i
wonder if it was
yeah maybe it wasn't her cat maybe it
was a neighborhood cat i don't know i
don't even know why the neighborhood cat
you think they'd like avoid that place
yeah they'd be like yeah [ __ ] that's
nasty [ __ ] there man no amount of
temptations treats are gonna like tempt
me everywhere
although cats kind of like stinky things
but not poop though i don't think
yeah well no animals don't like that
[ __ ]
well it might attract an animal if
they're coming what's that to
investigate what that smell is but
they're not going to want to stay there
once they figure out what that is
yeah yeah it was just it was terrible
but yeah it's um i think 2b has hoarders
like seasons 6 through maybe 12
which i'm not sure what the new one is
that they just put up on netflix not too
long ago
but if you want to watch some of the old
ones they have them on to be
if you're in the us like i said i don't
know i don't know if uh
europe or other countries have to be or
not it's actually pretty good
service they have a bunch of [ __ ] on it
it's very frustrating because there's a
lot of people that have these kind of
[ __ ] problems and
problems like that can only they only
exist in people that are supported by
a high civilization or you know society
actually those people exist because
society allows them to exist
if they were out in the wild living like
[ __ ] cro-magnon or [ __ ] you know
what i mean the native americans that
wouldn't be tolerated
imagine if that [ __ ] lived in a native
american society that was like say like
like like like say that the [ __ ]
lakota
yeah no the lakota would have killed her
they just throw her off
they throw her off the [ __ ] cliff or
they'd [ __ ] do something like what
are you doing
or alive with seashells or
set her on fire or something like that
because they would just assume that
well it depends they wouldn't see that
that was insanity though
because evidently most native americans
thought that insane people were kind of
untouchables that they might
be there might be they're like they're
like living haunted houses
that they were kind of scared of them
you know and they just
didn't want them around but they
wouldn't kill them either it's like bad
luck
yeah but i don't think they would have
thought that she was insane they just
would have thought she was a terribly
[ __ ]
nasty yeah yeah and just go you know
this we got to destroy this this is
something
impure and unholy you know because it's
not obvious
if you don't know anything about mental
illness and another thing that i think
is weird too is that
hoarding disorder is on the same kind of
spectrum or the same like
you know area as ocd and
ocd i mean i think a lot of people
associate ocd with people that are like
super super
clean or germ phobic that's not the only
kind that there is
um but it just seems like really weird
that those two
uh which seem like super clean and like
super dirty at like two
even though it's kind of the same it's
like two sides of the same coin kind of
it's weird that they never really
you know they they never really report
they report
you know they report insanity in
primitive cultures
but never anything like ocd you know
yeah most of the stuff that was reported
was usually associated with like a
mental breaks
like tragedy or inbreeding well things
like i am breathing things like ocd
depending on what type you have
it's not really um you're not really
having a huge
like detrimental effect on people you
know what i mean like
at large but could like say a pirate
have ocd
sure why not and he could get away but
anybody could nobody would notice it
well i don't know if they wouldn't
notice it but maybe they would just
think he was weird and that's like all
you know what i mean it's just like oh
he's the pirate but he just keeps going
going around like combing the [ __ ]
fringe on the rug and [ __ ] like that
yeah because it depends on what kind of
ocd we're talking that's what i mean
it's like i i feel like most people when
you say ocd people are like
a lot of big people that are like
germaphobic or people that like
you know want to clean everything or
straighten everything all the time but
that's not the only kind that there is
yeah ocd is basically any
anything that you have that is just like
um a recurring thought in your head that
makes you have to act on it like it's
like oh i have to
go and lock all the doors i have to
touch all the doorknobs i have to do
this and you can't stop yourself from
doing it yeah until theoretically
somebody like blackbeard could have ocg
it's just that you wouldn't the the
people the people of the time wouldn't
have recognized it for what it was
right like we don't know why he keeps
like checking that yeah because it's not
obviously
honestly insanity right they're not
obviously like acting like
all crazy or anything like that it's
just people would just think oh he's a
little weird
yeah but you couldn't you couldn't be
saving [ __ ] in bottles and be [ __ ]
blackbeard though they'd throw you
they'd kill all your ass
[Laughter]
now we're getting into the whole area of
like how dirty were pirates
it's like they were dirty man but they
weren't that [ __ ] dirty
how much of a hoarder would you have to
be before even the pirates turned
against
you well i kind of have a feeling though
that the [ __ ] that you know
they were they were at sea and um
you know based on based on everything
that i know about them [ __ ] pirates
tended to be dandies too they [ __ ]
wore fancy clothes and they had money
especially like because they were
sharing the [ __ ] booty you know
that they were stealing yeah so they had
fancy the booty and the booty
and yeah and there are also females in
the crew
which that's not that's not discussed a
lot but usually usually pirate ships had
women on them
yeah um so
well i forgot what i was getting at
i don't think they were that dirty
because they probably got wet quite
regularly
maybe they were just chaffed all the
time you have to watch
they were probably washing clothes and
throwing buckets overboard and bringing
bringing [ __ ] sea water up and
[ __ ] dousing themselves with seawater
they probably were
cleaner than people thought they were
well they're probably cleaner than
people living on land like back in those
days back in those days probably when
they had open sewers you didn't have
flush toilets or
bathtubs in your house yeah there's no
sewage system so everything has to go
overboard
and so you know what i mean it's not
pooping up the ocean though yeah
well the fish don't mind they love that
[ __ ] yeah the fish are already
officially yeah
all right yeah they're just like oh more
poop yes we're already
imagine a [ __ ] blue whale taking a
dump that's what i was just thinking of
actually
be the size of the [ __ ] the size of a
[ __ ] truck
you know i'm gonna have to google that
after we stopped the live stream
like how big a wheelchair is a blue
whale
probably [ __ ] 50 gallons of [ __ ] when
it takes a [ __ ] ew
and i wonder is it like all liquidy
probably or solid
probably i have never heard anybody talk
about a blue whale taking a dump but
they
that's like crazy yeah you know what
grosses me out the one
it's really funny because i used to
watch like a lot of nature documentaries
and stuff
and one thing that always uh kind of
stuck with me
is that hippos will poop
in the water and then they take their
tail and like swish it all around
to hide it i guess or just because
they're dicks okay
because hippos are mean well here's the
deal you know what i mean [ __ ]
in in the animal kingdom you know
the excrement of one animal is the food
for other ones
yeah you know i mean bacteria come and
[ __ ] flies and stuff
everything's [ __ ] consumed and those
little poop beetles in
the environment inside a house is not
the same
there isn't an ecosystem outside well
there is there is
not really not enough to [ __ ] not
enough to absorb that much [ __ ] in that
small of an area you're living in your
own [ __ ] that's stupid
i don't even think i don't even think uh
i think
bert most birds would be real careful
about getting [ __ ] inside their nests
yeah because that's a really small area
right so you know what i mean so i just
they seem to be pretty
they seem to be pretty ocd about how the
nest is a lot of species of birds
what the nest is made out of and why
poop in your nest when you can just poop
on a human's head who's walking under
your
tree that's like way more fun or poop on
their windshield
they're doing that on purpose you know
they are but yeah um what else i was
gonna say something else and i totally
forgot what it was
whoa my mind just went ken's talking
about the ghost ship episode story they
were towing the dinghy
maybe somebody put the problem person in
the diggy before the tragedy yeah
i don't know they're like put them out
there in that boat where they can't
[ __ ] on everything they may have jumped
into dinghy to get away from fumes
that's what i think i think it might
have been yeah because uh
i think maybe they thought the ship was
going to blow up oh elsa just uh
googled it the blue whale pooping okay
it looks like a jet stream
it does it looks like a gym i kind of
figured it was probably liquid right
because
i don't know why it's like it's you're
in the ocean so i don't think you're
doing like big salad turds you'd be like
should
be washing up on the beach and [ __ ] yeah
that'd be horrible
speaking of which today's tuesday or
wednesday wednesday wednesday okay um
so i kept waiting all last night for
that [ __ ] tv to come back on because
the poltergeist
yeah but it didn't never did i guess
because i warned
your your poltergeist essence
yeah i was like don't you wake me up
because i'm like tired as
like i don't want that [ __ ] tv
popping on it
that [ __ ] do that [ __ ] three times and
[ __ ] two times it did yeah
now what did happen was that
last night well no i was i was watching
the last sugar rush and you fell asleep
like before me yeah like i watched like
the last 10 or 20 minutes of the show
and then i turned the xbox off yeah
and then i turned the tv off
but then it popped back on it did like
but but it was like immediate so i don't
know if like i did that or if i [ __ ]
it up or something like that so i don't
i'm not attributing that to pairing that
blue screen came up that weird yet again
or was it it was too soon it was too
close it was too close i still had the
the remote in my hand i was or i was
putting the remote down
and then it popped back up and mostly i
was just mad i was just like god damn it
yeah so it's like i thought that was
probably me that time
but now that we're talking about it
again it's probably gonna do it tonight
just because of like at least it's not
breaking anything not yet
yeah let's not get i mean yeah
pookie would freak out pookie would
freak out if she saw stuff like [ __ ]
flying around
what if it picked pookie up no i don't
think look i don't think a cat would
notice it
you don't think probably not i kind of
feel like
i don't know i say this i would have
been confused okay imagine if pookie was
in the room when the remote [ __ ]
flew i mean it took a lot it took people
a few seconds to realize what had
happened i don't think a cat would
[ __ ]
tune in too much or whatever yeah well
don't they always say
though the way it was at mammoth a cat
would have
not liked that a cat would freaked out i
believe
yeah there was a palpable sensation of a
presence
well that's what i'm saying doesn't
everybody like all those paranormal
shows and [ __ ] they always say that like
oh
the animals are like acting weird
because now every time that pookie is
like doing something and then she stops
and like looks over at the wall or
something i'm like is there a ghost over
there you can tell me
you can tell me a lot of the ones about
the animals about the animals acting
weird is because it was on animal planet
and they
in order to get the funding they have to
have an animal in the [ __ ] store
i don't know if you guys didn't know
that that was like yeah there was like
all this paranormal [ __ ] i don't even
know if the shit's still out anymore
but they had all these paranormal shows
they they're usually on destination
america or annie or whatever the [ __ ]
channel they were on
and then but then you had the animal
planet and they're like well we want
some of that sweet paranormal cash as
well
so they had their own show that was
paranormal
and it was just so funny the way i mean
because it was just like basically a
straight-up paranormal
show and then like they like they would
have two seconds we're like yeah the cat
like looked at the wall one time
yeah and then like back to the ghost
story just to justify it being on animal
planet
what the [ __ ] was the name of that show
i can't remember
animal hauntings wasn't it or no i don't
even i don't even think it had the name
animal
in it american american hauntings or
something
but i didn't i don't remember what it
was because there's so many yeah but it
was on animal planet it was on animal
planet so they just had
they had to be like well we have to just
at least have one mention where the dog
or the kitty in the house
yeah like you know act reacted funny
when they heard something right
well that's that's how they got the
funding to get it on the [ __ ] channel
right
because they really wanted a paranormal
show
i was like watch you know what i think
that nowadays
um because sometimes i get like emails
from the travel channel or something
because i somehow got on their mailing
list
but i think the travel channel is almost
all paranormal shows now
wow almost all like they have always
watching it except ghost people
that's what i mean so it's like
paranormal tv is like still pretty big i
guess because it's like every time that
i see like i get an email from travel
channel and it has their little schedule
over there it's like all paranormal
shows
well look at cable we have cable we
never use it it just like
almost comes for free with our internet
service and
it's like what an extra ten dollars yeah
and then everyone you know we were
watching [ __ ] uh
i watched gordon ramsay on it yeah and
then oh which reminds me we still have
like we got a bunch of those
two or three of those uh those travel
shows of his that
and then there was also the other yeah
but that sucks now i think well i
kind of forgot what happened in the last
what happened was i i saw that the new
season was on but i forgot what happened
in the last season so i was gonna wait
until netflix with the last season on so
i could re-watch the last season so i
could catch up and then watch the new
one
when that as soon as it went from a
brutal survival horror [ __ ] series to
almost kind of
like a female oriented soap opera that i
i just [ __ ] i just
lost it my intentions i know females are
the worst well nobody was getting killed
nobody was getting killed god damn it
killed people it was becoming a [ __ ]
series about relationships and [ __ ]
that's that's not what that's not what i
signed on for
that's telling you that's not what i
[ __ ] said before
it's [ __ ] free you guys know what i'm
talking about
those first three seasons were [ __ ]
good man
yeah one of these days i'll watch the
whole thing back over again tammy says
my cat acts weird all the time i
wouldn't notice anything different yeah
probably i mean already pookie is just
like every now and then she goes what
and then like [ __ ] runs off into the
other room for whatever reason
but yeah uh beijing when beijing was in
my office this morning sitting in my
office chair
she doesn't usually sit in here she just
comes in here and steals the
little stuffed animals off the shelves
and lays them around everywhere
but she was sitting in there and then
pookie came in and pookie wanted to
investigate the new chair
and so beijing was just like not having
it she was
growling and hissing and it's weird
because
they hang out you know what i mean like
they're not
when when we first got pookie beijing
was just really really
unhappy and she was just always like you
duck i hate you baby and she was always
like hitting her and
you know growling and hissing at her and
stuff but over time
now they'll kind of like hang out but i
mean if pookie like ever
oversteps the bounds beijing is just
gonna like
and she always is over step at the
bounce well yeah because pookie never
learns
she's like she grabs her
it's [ __ ] funny she's like she
doesn't care she knows beijing's not
gonna do anything bad
like other than his at her she doesn't
like hurt her or anything
so it's just kind of like she'll she'll
just do something and then be like oh
okay sorry but then like two seconds
later she's like ah
then she does it again so i don't know
beijing might dig it i don't know maybe
that's their little game that they play
i don't really think you're like a
little kid yeah because you know beijing
was like a lot older and then we got
this little tiny baby and i thought
when we first got the baby i was kind of
like maybe beijing will be like that'll
here be her maternal instincts
but beijing does not have any maternal
instincts no she was just like [ __ ] that
little baby
yeah i'm the pretty queen in here it's
like i don't want some other little baby
like [ __ ] up my [ __ ]
and being all in my space how long we've
been streaming for uh
i don't know 30 something 30 minutes 38
minutes you guys got any questions or
anything
oh happy birthday caleb yeah happy
birthday to you
those darn females and their soap operas
right i'm a female and i don't like soap
operas
well just you know i got soapy i don't
like
soap operas i don't like romance novels
i don't like that and they came out with
fear of the walking dead and that
was promising but then it's it just
[ __ ] well it was promising and then
it kind of sucked but then it got really
good again but then i kind of forgot
about it yeah and you're like yeah
whatever
because it got really good again because
they killed off almost everybody
yeah well it started off with this it
started off with kind of bad characters
looking back on it now
they weren't that good at characters how
could they how could they couldn't
compete with the
the cast on yeah but i mean you know
it's like
it's too hard to like get a cast i mean
the cast that they had on the original
walking dead was like lightning in a
bottle like all of the
chemistry between them and stuff a lot
of it had to do with the writing though
alex says uh that he has a question for
you what's that
there was one time you told the story
about finding your first goth album in
the garbage
yeah was that in brazil or america that
was it that was in uh
that was in um trenton michigan
trenton michigan yeah down river from
detroit who was throwing away perfectly
good sisters of mercy and bauhaus albums
uh no it was just the sisters of mercy
album but
the bauhaus wasn't in it oh okay it was
just and it was um
man i remember it was an alice it was it
was the one with alice on it yeah which
i think that was
it was a single it was so like an ep
it's like an ep like i had four or five
songs
yeah yeah yeah and alice was was and
it's just a black album with a [ __ ]
white
star in that damn head yeah on it
that's how i remembered it was a long
time ago the album was slightly damaged
a little bit but uh it didn't matter i
just got more of them
yeah but that's how i discovered that
bat that's really funny like of all the
things to find in the garbage we're
sticking up about
top of a garbage can and there were no
other albums in there or anything like
that i can't remember
that's so strange i thought i remember i
just wanted like
maybe somebody just bought it and they
were like man [ __ ] this
somebody didn't like it it was like it
was a gift or something and they didn't
like it
that's all i ever think of maybe maybe
i don't know i i can't i i i yeah i
can't imagine like the
the sequence of events that led up to
that being maybe somebody's parents
threw it out
oh yeah maybe i don't know like so
there's like this but i don't know who
lived there parents were like
fundamentalists or something
like that but that was the only thing i
remember that was just kind of sticking
up and there was just
i don't really spend so long i just
remember it kind of sticking up
and i don't think it was in the garbage
can it was in a pile or something next
to the garbage can
okay i mean like something that all been
stacked up yeah i think it might have
been on top of like
some old furniture like what do you call
it like so maybe somebody moved or
something something like that or maybe
somebody that lives there like died or
something and then like somebody else
moved all their [ __ ] out of this
there was like some old chairs or
something it was a [ __ ] record album
sitting on top of it
yeah it's like it's like an afterthought
like somebody just put layout get rid of
that too
i think it was it but you know this
we're talking about the 80s
a long time ago yeah i think it must
have been around
uh 86 maybe no before that probably 85.
maria says hey tom i'm now officially a
disabled vet too va accepted my claim
all right what percentage did you get
what percentage
that's what's really important yeah yeah
alex was saying because i was curious if
goth was popular in brazil at all at
that time
yeah i feel like gotha's been
pretty popular in like uh central and
south america
almost from the beginning yeah i mean
from what i perceived
i mean in brazil you know just a couple
years later i went back to brazil and
you had [ __ ]
you had sisters of mercy about house
christian death they knew about that
you know ross williams versus christian
death um
trying to think they were listening to
specimen
they were listening to um um
i think that's about it that's from what
i remember yeah a long time ago
virgin prunes they might have no i think
they had that
oh that's good good taste yeah
but that was from what i remember from
from goth music that was down there
but they i'm trying to think what else
later on in the 90s here in the you know
it started to become more like
switchblade symphony that kind of that
yeah went more in a dark wavy game yeah
my dark wave
then um but really what was much bigger
than
gotham in brazil was [ __ ] metal they
loved iron maiden
jesus priest [ __ ] like that pantera
metallica they [ __ ] love that stuff i
feel like it kind of all goes together
though i mean you usually get like the
there's some crossover yeah that's what
i mean like not a huge amount but
you know it's usually like kind of like
adjacent subcultures
what i was listening to uh goth goth i
also like listen to a lot of dancing
and and misfits yeah you know
man my brother's band used to play all
kind of misfits because sam
or sell bond if you want to be like
[ __ ]
pretentious about it guys she got 70
that's good 70 is good
yeah do you guys like killing joke i do
i need more of their [ __ ] but i have
like um
three or four other albums i think
but yeah they're a very good band also
they had um
[ __ ] man what the [ __ ] was the name of
the album that they had a few years ago
absolute descent maybe and i actually
really like that that was a
that's some really good songs on it they
kind of
you know they seem to have gone into
more
kind of metal direction too so did
fields of the nephilim because i feel
like
a few years ago i picked up a new yeah
fields of the netherlands
nephilim album and it's like pretty much
straight up black metal yeah
which well i guess they lost their they
lost their goth
[ __ ] the goth scene for live music
just
kind of vanished you know i mean the
bigger crowds i guess were the metal
crowds
i guess that's they're just like going
where the money is because they're like
yeah man i don't want to get a real job
[ __ ] that
i mean even andrew eldridge [ __ ]
[ __ ] can't tour hardly
you know when he tours he tours like
places like mexico
yeah mexico and central america i've
seen him a bunch of times
yeah it's yeah last time i saw him was
well several years ago yeah bald
i like the way um well i mean he shaved
his head yeah i don't know how bald he
is because he shaved his head because
he's bald
probably it's funny because they uh
they pretty much just cover the stage
and smoke so you can barely see anything
i'm like that could be anybody yeah
that's a good show people that have
dealt with him said that he's [ __ ]
crazy and dishonest
so what was funny is that like you know
that uh the tour with
patricia moore the album of patricia
morrison yeah yeah floodland floodland
flood land in flood land she is not in
that album and she never toured
that tour never happened she was only in
the music video and on the album cover
isn't that funny she married davey and
like everything fell apart
that whole thing fell apart quite
quickly she was only
maybe she couldn't put up with his ass
he evidently ran off with the money the
tour money
hmm like they got a bunch of fun to buy
some speed it had to do
probably probably
and something went wrong you know i
think he he ran off with the [ __ ]
the tour money and then the uh i think
his the
and i think that tour money was actually
from the record company and the [ __ ]
record company well yeah
when you're on a major label they give
you money like right
that's what happened to him that's what
that he made up a story how he did it in
protest
okay and that's like saying something
[ __ ] up and then going i was just
joking
yeah but yeah so it reminded me you
saying that reminded me of this
interview that i saw with nick cave one
time like a long time ago
and they were talking about i can't
remember what video it was like a music
video
and um he was like maybe it was the
weeping song
but it was like one of the kind of
cheaper videos and he said uh
this this video right here is an example
of
how like record companies should not let
us do a video they're like first of all
don't give me the money he's like
because
the money was spent on other things
as in heroin
he spent it on airplanes yeah so they
didn't have all that much left so they
had to like
i'm pretty sure it was weeping song
because that was the one with him at
blix and bargail
bargailed in the boat and then the the
ocean was just like garbage bags or
something
it still looks cool but it's like you
know i just thought that was really
funny that he said don't give me the
money
because he just spent it on drugs all
right so uh we've been going what 47
minutes
yeah you're gonna go make some food yeah
maybe somebody
make some chicken chimichangas you're
gonna make chicken chicken yeah
cream cheese i'm like not even drunk and
i can't even talk
you know it's wednesday afternoon i'm
not drunk i swear to god i just can't
really talk
all right so uh next time we stream it's
probably gonna be saturday
uh i got a super fun show coming up no
more
no true crime this week we're just going
to do well maybe a little bit of true
crime but we're going to do like a fun
kind of
variety type of show but i'm not going
to tell you what it is i told you but
you probably don't remember
i don't remember all right so uh
we'll talk to you guys later and uh
thanks for dropping by bye